[Musique]
Alexandra strilisky vient de faire
paraître néo romance son troisième album
alors qu'ils disent que précédent avait
été composé au cours d'une période
sombre de sa vie celui-ci est le fruit
de Namour naissant ce qui m'intéresse
dans l'idée de retomber en amour c'est
l'espèce de vulnérabilité qui vient avec
le fait de réouvrir son cœur parce que
quand on a connu des peines d'amour
il faut faire un effort conscient de se
dire tiens je vais refaire ça c'est
comment on reste amoureux quand on sait
qu'on peut perdre
le titre Neo romance fait aussi
référence au compositeurs romantiques
comme Chopin Shuman ou Wagner je
m'associe plus au composteur romantique
dans le sens où il évoque des grands
thèmes l'amour la mort c'est l'émotion
et spontanée et puis ça c'est quelque
chose qui qui dans lequel je me
reconnais quand même beaucoup parce que
c'est la façon dont je crie depuis
toujours donc je mais c'est aussi l'idée
de ce que c'est aujourd'hui être un
compositeur romantique
et Alexandre astrellisky le vent dans
les voiles inspepe son disque précédent
a remporté 5 Félix un Juno s'est vendu à
160 000 exemplaires et cumulent plus de
300 millions d'écottants en ligne elle
est signée avec Sony musique ce qui lui
permet avec nos romances d'avoir des
visites internationales
avec deux associés et la par ailleurs
acquis en 2021 le studio la majeur
spécialisé dans la musique animale
j'adore le cinéma moi dans ma vie j'aime
peut-être plus la bouffe et le cinéma
que la musique c'est drôle à dire mais
je suis vraiment une passionnée de ça
j'aime les histoires je vais me raconter
des histoires oui le film c'est sûr que
dès que j'ai un peu de temps je vais
vouloir prendre un projet de musique à
l'image et de développer ce côté-là de
ma carrière
mais il lui faudra sans doute faire
preuve de patience parce que la tournée
néo romance commence à peine et que des
concerts sont prévus jusqu'en juin 2024
ce qui concrétise vraiment la vie d'un
album ce sont les spectacles après la
musique prend un sens différent aussi à
bout j'ai des formes qui s'ouvrent et je
suis sûr que ça va être rempli de
découverte donc ça j'ai très hâte
Alexandre astrelisky sera en concert les
11 et les 12 avril à la salle Louis de
fried Pelletier de la Place des Arts
elle s'envolera ensuite pour une tournée
européenne d'une dizaine de dates
Alexandre Chartier Radio-Canada Montréal
[Musique]